who's in court what was said well he's a
York he was in court what was that in
court shinki
the three-year-old student from York has
been found guilty of a section 4 public
order offense and as a result of that
he's been sentenced to a community order
that will last 12 months over that
course of time he will need to undertake
a hundred hours of community work he
also will have to cover the 600 pound
costs in 600 pound prosecution cost also
and he took the unusual step of
providing his own defense in court today
and he said that the reason for what he
did was about the broader issues caused
by the monarchy he cited a number of
things from colonialism to issues around
climate change and a bigger suspicion of
authority in general when it when the
court case was over he spoke to us
outside talking about some of those
things here's what he had to say
I hope that it hits Sparks conversation
and I hope that the conversation
continues going forward I'm going to
continue advocating for a democratic
Confederation of the British Isles
rejecting not just the monarchy but
parliamentary rule all together and
moving to a system of direct democracy
where people make decisions that affect
their own lives and so if that's what I
had to do to get this platform where
you're all stood about me then uh you
know yeah worth it
so that was Patrick Farwell there but
those arguments did not wash with the
judge he said that it wasn't about those
broader issues it was about the
indisputable facts and the facts are
that Patrick farewell threw five eggs at
the king during that walk about on
November 9th last year after he had been
here unveiling a statue of his mother in
his summing up remarks he said that the
defendant used threatening abusive and
insulting words or behavior and then he
went on to say that he intended his
behavior to be threatening and abusive
and he intended to cause King Charles
and or others immediate or unlawful
violence so he has been found guilty of
a section for public order offense
okay shingy thank you